la vème république est née
1958 la vème république est née nouvelle
constitution nouvelle assemblée sur tout
nouveau député leur nombre est fixé à
179,2 de plus qu'aujourd'hui déjà le
palais bourbon est animée avec les
nouveaux élus on les a vus arriver
conscients de leurs responsabilités mais
souriant pour prendre contact avec les
lieux et les usages quatre ans plus tard
en 1962 première évolution conséquence
de la décolonisation le nombre d'élus
baisse et passe de 579 à 482 en france
l'installation de la deuxième assemblée
de la vème république a ranimé les
travées de l'hémicycle du palais bourbon
et au palais bourbon les sièges se font
et se défont après 1962 le nombre de
députés va repartir à la hausse avec la
réorganisation des départements
franciliens en 1967 et lyonnais en 1973
l'assemblée compte 490 élu avec quelques
originalités un père et un fils son
député monsieur louis joxe député du
rhône et pierre joxe député de saône et
loire il y aura aussi des anonymes qui
siégeront ensemble messieurs paul et
michel durafour messieurs alain et
robert andré vivien mais il y aura
surtout trois forts au palais bourbon
après 1973 peu de mouvement dans
l'hémicycle hormis un siège
supplémentaire il faudra attendre 1986
pour qu'un nouveau changement s'opère
577 députés au lieu de 491 il a fallu
ajouter des sièges dans l'hémicycle
supprimer quelques travées équiper les
nouvelles places du système de vote
électronique
c'est une décision du président
mitterrand il augmente le nombre de
sièges à l'assemblée en même temps qu'il
instaure le scrutin à la proportionnelle
résultat la majorité de droite n'est pas
toute puissante et l'extrême droite
entre dans l'hémicycle
on bricole essentiellement aux
extrémités de l'hémicycle mais parfois
les menuisiers en quelques états d'âme
je pense que ce soit pour l'extrême
droite ça me dérange encore plus nous
mais premier ministre jacques chirac
supprime la proportionnelle sans revenir
sur le nombre de sièges de députés
depuis il n'a pas changé toujours sans
177 même si on a parfois du mal à s'en
rappeler j'ai pas connaissant les
cendres au public aucune idée y'en a
trop de toute manière mon bonheur nous
ne dépend pas du nombre de députés
[Musique]